und ich sehe aus wie ein durch gebeiztes
eichhörnchen was seine seiten nicht
geschnitten hat etwas club willkommen
beim ein video
ja ich habe eben einfach mal so ein paar
meiner alten videos geschaut und ich war
auch mal auf meinem alten instagram
profil weil das habe ich irgendwie eben
wieder gefunden so wirklich bilder von
vor drei jahren da wurde instagram
gerade entwickelt oder kam raus und ich
habe direkt schon ins profil auf jeden
fall ist wieder so aufgefallen meine
haare die hatten ja schon so über die
letzten drei vier jahre eine krasse
entwicklung und ich habe einfach mal für
dieses video heute so ungefähr 10 11
screenshots oder bilder von mir
ausgesucht die als so die entwicklung
meiner haare widerspiegeln ich finde es
einfach interessant ist mal so zu sehen
und ich weiß auch dass irgendwie meine
haare immer so ein magnet für euch sind
als immer wenn ich schreibe ja irgendwas
passiert mit meinen hart dann freut ihr
euch irgendwie voll und klickt alle das
video an und ich finds halt auch selber
total spannend zu irgendwas in mainhardt
anzustellen oder darüber videos zu
machen ja und deswegen würde ich sagen
gibt's heute dieses video ich will gar
nicht lange bleiben und wir fahren so
volkmann und ihr könnt ja mal schreiben
wie die entwicklung findet und ja dieses
video wird für mich mal wieder ein
bisschen peinlich aber das gehört dazu
ich finde das ist ganz normal dass man
vor drei vier jahren auch mal scheiße
aus wir fangen an so das erste bild
kommt vom 15
und es dieses hier das ist aus irgend
einem youtube video und screenshots also
das müsste wirklich somit mein erstes
youtube-video gewesen sein
und wenn man mich da so anguckt geht zum
friseur ich weiß ich was ich mir dabei
gedacht habe so warum zu laufen also das
bild stammt vom fünften ersten 2012 und
2012 waren wirklich das jahr wo ich mir
gedacht habe so 8 kommentare so denken
wir zwar jetzt auch manchmal aber das
war wirklich krass und dann auch zum 10
4 hin hat sich das so entwickelt dass
sie einfach komplett abstand und
hässlich ausland ich musste mir wirklich
jeden tag in der schule anderen so ich
geh mal zum friseur aber irgendwie
überhaupt nicht gestört so und weiß
nicht wer das war echt krass wenn ich
wenn ich mich selbst daran zurück
erinnere okay machen wir weiter mit dem
nächsten bild das ist dieses hier vom
ersten 2012 und zweitens krien schaut
aus dem alten video von mir das hier
speed nie war die reihe
und da sieht man mich auf der linken
seite und da war ich beim friseur
man sieht wirklich so aus wie 10 aber
ich war schon 14
fast 15 ich finde da würde ich jetzt
meine haare sagen die sind halt einfach
kurz und einfach darauf sucht einfach
dort nichts mitgebracht die sind einfach
nur da ist einige zeit nichts besonderes
mit meinen haaren passiert das bild ist
vom 5 17 20 13 10 das habe ich auch beim
alten instagram account gesehen der
heißt alex w 15 könnt ihr mal
vorbeischauen und abonnieren
macht's besser nicht weil die bilder
sehen alles was mit so einem ekligen htc
handy da habe ich meine haare da ein
bisschen hoch gemacht und wenn man dann
mal weiter guckt das bild vom 23 08 2012
da sind die haare eigentlich noch
genauso also im jahr 2013 ist dann nicht
so viel mit passiert und ich glaube auch
im jahr 2014 habe ich die ganze zeit nur
so getragen also einfach haare ab und zu
mal hoch gemacht ab und so waren die
einfach nur da ab und zu ihr wisst was
ich meine so kann er mit seiner seele
okay das jahr 2014 war dann vorbei da
war ich auch nicht so aktiv im netz mit
dem slogan deine scheiss regel auf jeden
fall 2014 ich war nicht so aktiv im
metal das nächste bild kommt dann vom 10
12 01 15
und zwar ist es dieses hier wo man sieht
dass meine haare eigentlich immer nur
noch einfach da sind aber sie sind
wieder länger geworden und ich sehe aus
wie ein durch gebotes eichhörnchen was
seine seiten nicht geschnitten hat so
ungefähr kann man sagen es sieht echt
irgendwie witzig aus so einfach so
komplett mein gott meine ganze frisur
steht einfach aber im jahr 2015 ist dann
auch erstmal nicht viel passiert damit
die waren immer noch einfach nur da und
dann hab ich mir am 27 12 20 15 gedacht
acom herbst doch einfach mal deine haare
blond das war doch ein wirklich
eigentlich ein cooler farbton also ich
habe es mehr gefeiert anfangen und das
war dann aber irgendwie nach 23 monaten
auch wieder weg was ich etwas schade
fand dann kam der dritte siebte 2016 wo
ich einfach mal dachte privat komm ich
gehe nicht zum friseur
ich werde mir meine haare einfach mal
selber und was da rauskamen ist
folgendes wir nehmen einfach mal ein
idol und ein alex und tun das eignet auf
alex kopf und haben alex neu ich sehe
einfach komplett scheiße aus da dachte
aber sofort dann kommen geht zum friseur
und am 17.7 2016 sah das ganze dann
schon einigermaßen akzeptabel aus ich
hatte zwar weiße haare irgendwie aber
das sah so aus
so und dann folgte auch schon ich glaube
das war der 88 2016 wo sich der liebe
alex wie dachte kommen du musst jetzt
was krasses raushauen und macht ihr
einfach dreadlocks das habe ich auch
gemacht und dann sage ich einfach mal
komplett scheiße aus für zwei wochen und
zwar so aber das wisst ihr
wahrscheinlich alle ja das war würde ich
mal sagen so der höhepunkt meiner
karriere
was da noch alles auf euch zukommt jetzt
gerade sehen meine haare einfach so aus
ach du scheiße was ist jetzt los
wartet also ich bin eben aufgestanden
habe meine kappe aufgesetzt um dieses
video gedreht praktisch jetzt gerade
sind sie noch blond
die sind ziemlich lang was damit
passiert werden wir bald erfahren ich
habe auf jeden fall negativ darauf an
sonst würde ich sagen schreib doch mal
in die kommentare
welches bild oder wann findet ihr meine
haare am coolsten so wie sie jetzt sind
oder waren meine trades auch cool seit
auf jeden fall gespannt auf sonntag weil
am sonntag kommt ein musikvideo raus um
14 uhr deswegen check ist auf jeden fall
ab und lassen noch nach oben wird mich
persönlich sehr freuen also jetzt den
daumen nach oben fressen und wir sehen
das vielleicht sogar morgen noch einmal
wieder also bevor sonntag sonntag wird
echt der coolste tag der woche weiter
das video rauskommt und ich bin
eigentlich sogar ganz zufrieden damit
dass auf jeden fall ab aber vielleicht
komme auch video wer weiß
wir sehen uns instagram folgen locker an
machen neben abonnieren -button und haut
rein weiteres geht es gar nicht